yeah this video is finally happening
yeah first of all I got to thank you all
for your patience I have been fugly sick
I flew in a fever for the past four or
five days my temperature just went down
to 99 so like hey I kinda don't feel
like I'm completely floating out of my
head maybe I can do that video on the
Captain America civil war trailer
featuring spider-man oh my god this must
be blue overload for you guys how much
blue can you guys take um blue da ba dee
da that starts out in pornstache is
breaking down the events of the original
Avengers Captain America Civil War and
age of Ultron is like New York
Washington DC that little town way
across the world we obviously didn't
have cameras in but we had cameras in
because we have footage of the event is
like people are scared this must be
reined in which is really fun I notice
they're doing that thing that movies and
shows sometimes do which the security
footage is the camera that the director
used for this shot it's not security
footage it was a shot for the movie like
that's a shot from the movie so a bunch
of stuff we already knew Captain
America's like no not gonna happen Tony
Stark's like yeah it is it looks like he
gets really personal when Bucky Barnes
shoots Rhodey and an Iron Man gets
really pissed so piss like it I love
that scene where he just looks over and
he smacks Captain America and the mask
comes down he's like you just started a
war yes man of iron a civil war I really
love that scene where show Scarlett
which I like I get you my pretty and
then it shows visional like I get
controlled by it because of my last
video I was like dear they have the
vision who's gonna go up against that
and a lot of you guys were like of
Scarlet Witch she don't look good ed
will well fans one Jeremy zero good job
anything is this trailer doesn't show
you much more than what you already knew
we knew like Avengers and Marvel folks
are gonna fight and that's what this
trailer shows they're still fighting
then it shows us like sweet shot of all
of them like coming at each other and
you're like oh my guys it's exciting and
Tony Stark's like alright I've run out
of patience I believe he says on the
roof but it really sounds like on the
roof and I don't know what the ruse is
I'm like on the roof is that what our
Rouge anyhow point is it doesn't matter
because spider-man's web comes down
snatches cap shield binds caps arms and
spider-man comes around and bam lands
with the shield means like hey guys
which when I first saw a picture of
spider-man his black around his eyes was
like well it's like 1960 spider-man it
still does feel like 1960s spider-man
but then I was like oh wait I'll bet
you're they're going to do the Deadpool
thing where his eyes are going to move
and be expressive and they totally do
because he squints when he says hey guys
which I'm down for that and let's face
it we had 90 Spider Man suit and we had
New Age spider-man student back to 90
spider-man stay well let's just go back
to 1960 spider-man suit he does look a
bit cgi in here so we'll see how it goes
either it's CGI or I think it's CGI and
it's actually a real costume in which
case I'm like I guess CGI had reals I
can't tell the difference anymore
I hope he's not in two scenes because
they got the rights too late and just
kind of shoehorn him in a couple suits I
hope he's a very pivotal part in this
movie although I don't know I'm
reserving judgment on that what is I'm
looking forward to our heroes fighting
my friends what is family if you cannot
have a solid family feud it's gonna be
fine this trailer looks awesome one
thing that is not awesome
I'm really sorry my energy is down but
again like I said I have been [ __ ] up
out on fever [ __ ] so I'm going to edit
this I'm gonna upload it and I'm gonna
pass back out it's gonna be good but
guys the Captain America civil war
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it what did you think of
spider-man's unveiling here whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you